- So "Legally Blonde" is 20-years old.
We've talked about what's accurate,
let's talk about what's not
accurate about this show.
- Yeah. Let's commence
with our usual torture.
- 1L classes at Harvard being taught
by a practicing lawyer,
not going to happen.
The 1L classes are usually taught
by some very prestigious professor
who was only a professor.
There are practicing lawyers who teach,
but not in your 1L year
and not at Harvard Law.
1L's competing for an
in-school internship?
- You will also be competing
for one of my firm's
highly coveted four internship spots.
- What? You don't have a job
when you're in law school,
at least not at the top law schools.
You just simply don't have time
and you're not going to be competing
for some firm's internship
while you're in class.
It's just, you don't have time for it.
- You're fired.
I have no representation.
- Letting a first-year law
student try any portion
of a major homicide criminal
case, not going to happen.
That's insane.
And of course the most unrealistic thing,
law students having a social life.
- No way! Is somebody at the
school actually having a party?
- Not in your first year, you're not.
- This case is dismissed.